[Music]
what's up guys welcome back are we
live holy
[__] Jesus Christ give me a little
warning kill this one
too oh oh my
God
oh little seah
horsey now well you've seen a seahorse
nut right you seen that video right you
mean right that was way back on Vine was
it that yeah that clip it from some
national pull that up yeah look up the
seahorse nutting video we got to check
this out so you know male seahorses get
like
self yeah they like they can switch
right I don't know if it's that they
switch Yeah they have like ovaries and a
or something and they I just thought
gender is irrelevant cuz they both can
get prar I
see yeah okay when's this thing going to
nut oh who cares about the science
when's this thing going to
bust until finally oh there it
is it's like confetti yeah oh those like
just little yeah oh what the
[__] damn this thing is busting
ropes damn I started cute and now it's
like now it's pornographic
look wait three came out that one yeah
hang on I'm not quite finished I'm not
quite done what are these anime
subtitles hey hang on oh there we go I'm
watching Attack on Titan right now so
you know I'm turning weeb I've never
watched a single anime 1,00 neither have
uh no 1,800 babies yeah I watched pieces
of animes but you know it was all the
stuff on Cartoon Network tunami doesn't
really count oh yeah uh sorry we're just
back on the seahorse thing what what
what conversation are we in right now
well let's go to seahorse mode okay okay
the sperm producers so is the show like
is it good because like it's a good plot
or the female transfers her eggs to the
Mal you like the anime style of it the
male releases sper oh that's crazy
so that's crazy what network is it on
Hulu Hulu okay what's
crazy the the the
female seahorse passes oh no I only
spoilers I don't want to
spoiler I don't want to this the female
transfers her eggs to the male's
abdominal pouch made of modified skin
and the male [__]
himself no the male releases sperm to to
fertilize the eggs as they enter before
incubating them for 24 hours she hands
him a bunch of eggs and then he has a
flashlight built in yeah like a little
pouch
yeah yeah and then he busts in there yep
and then when it's time
blatow so does he carry the babies as
well yeah so what is the woman like
she's just off she's chilling chilling
it's just flipped yeah yeah true I guess
yeah it's flipped yeah humans other way
around the dudes are chilling yeah post
it up you know don't let don't let
standup Comics find out about
this uhoh I mean you just did though
uhoh oh you know I was watching a nature
documentary the other day oh yeah I hit
him with it and did you
know male seahorses carry the eggs
ladies imagine if you could give your
eggs to your to your husband and make
him carry wouldn't that be
chill then you could be on the couch
watching sports while he's in the
kitchen like I want
chocolate Jesus Christ
I don't think the women would like that
joke don't think so no Obie's laughing
yeah that's true actually Obie said she
liked that
one is that what you said I said I don't
know if that counts I don't know if that
counts oh what oh that's like a self-own
can you pop that one too this one yeah
why cuz I'm I I've been shadowed the
whole
time yeah [__] this one's full
oh it's a seahorse oh
cute he's going to give birth
now I'm about to
bust I'm about to I'm about
to suck on it I can't do it dude I'm
scared I'm a [__] dude I'm scared of it
helium yeah why right why you scared of
helium cuz I kind of think like it's
going to [__] with my lungs or something
I here here do it takes no
convincing no one said
anything oh yeah
man that's [__]
sick you did
it suck on the hole that I just sucked
on no I'm
good I hate doing this why it is a
little unnerving
right you're wasting it all dude oh no
that's good
here yeah man I love
wait yeah totally yeah that's
[Laughter]
sick oh [__] yeah this feels
bad am I playing along or no wow do it
one more time
okay can you like do too much though no
really doesn't like cut off oxygen to
your brain or some [__] oh
bro yo oh damn it good I'm a fat man um
damn I was trying to think of the
Walkman lyrics Faded shwing DRS like
Pacman hm yeah oh yeah here we
go my girl want to go raw she all in my
draws trying to give me roadhead I'm
like that's [__] dangerous what kind
of game is this we should do this at
home instead with a condom and a bed
damn it's last when's the last time we
had sex you might be stuck like that
dude we need to take a test before we
even think about sex I forget the
imagine if your voice just stayed like
that what what what he came home a
that's me hi
honey divorce papers
immediately we eting good yeah Alena
scrolled past the Tik Tok that started
playing I was like turn it off what
Walkman no I know it like rep popped
dude it had like I I saw that it was
like three of them went super viral and
it was like a I used to listen to this
song all the time and there was a bunch
of comments being like I I was today
years old when I found out this was Cody
and Noel but they they're like I've had
this on my playlist I've listened to it
a thousand [__] times and I didn't
realize this was
them people just gen genely like that
song it still gets like 10,000 streams a
day that is unreal isn't that [__]
crazy that is unreal don't you [__]
dare don't you dare oh you can hard it
that's fine yeah Harding it's fine but
you leave that little arrow alone don't
you dare don't you
dare I'll walk out of this
recording